a lot of games have drawn inspiration
from the works of from software with
varying degrees of success while many
developers look to emulate that high
degree of challenge that comes from the
likes of dark souls bloodborne and
sakura they often miss the fact that
it's from's thoughtful tight gameplay
and deliberate encounter design that
makes these games fun not just a
punishing difficulty phimesia a 3d
action game that draws heavily from some
specific from titles manages to strike
that balance successfully creating a
soul's like that taps into the same
rewarding moments provided by its
biggest inspirations
phi messiah draws most obviously from
two of from software's games the
aggressive horror-inspired bloodborne
and the fast-paced dual-focused sakuro
shadows die twice and to be sure
developer overboarder studio owes a lot
to its inspirations like bloodborne
thimesia is about a lone warrior
wandering into a plague-stricken world
where everyone infected has turned into
a maddened and bloodthirsty killer it
has similar atmosphere to bloodborne and
even its protagonist corvus looks a bit
like a yharnam hunter more accurately
hunter of hunters eileen the crow
thymessia takes place in a kingdom
called hermes in a world beset by a
plague that infects both people and
animals mutating them and turning them
into monsters as corvus a sort of
superpowered fighter with a connection
to the alchemists who are trying to cure
the plague your job in thy messiah is to
remember what has already happened each
level in the game is actually a lengthy
recollection of a past event and corvus
has previously ventured through three
different locales in the kingdom and
killed the monsters found there
uncovering information about experiments
to cure the plague the whole story is a
bit thin with little explanation spent
on who corvus is why he's such a great
fighter of flake monsters or how he got
these memories the other characters want
him to examine but the story is not the
star of the show in thy messiah that
instead is the fast-paced offense-heavy
gameplay that has you ripping through
small enemies and battling some tougher
more inventive bosses the key mechanics
of thymessia are basically ripped
straight out of bloodborne and sakura
and both are used to great effect
bloodborne is a game that eschews
blocking for aggression and dodging
while sakura mostly encourages players
to duel and deflect incoming attacks
with their blade dimesia puts major
focus on similar ideas you have a sword
in each hand for the entirety of the
game using them to slash away at enemies
and when timed correctly parry incoming
attacks you'll alternate between agile
avoidance and standing your ground
against a volley of blows tight
responsive controls and expressive
character animations mean that both
approaches are highly satisfying you'll
quickly learn to spot when you need to
parry an attack and get a knack for
where your dodges will take you and how
to best outmaneuver almost any foe the
game's fast combat works exceedingly
well finding the same tough but
rewarding cadence of both sakuro and
bloodborne though you'll occasionally
fight multiple enemies at a time
dimension is largely a game about tough
duels and carefully planning your
attacks you want to do as much damage to
your enemies as possible without
over-committing as in soulsborne games
hitting attack buttons can lock you into
animations that make you vulnerable to
counter-attack oftentimes defense is the
best offense since deflecting attacks
not only protects you it can wreck the
health bars of your opponents where
overboarder steps away from from
software is in how it deals with health
in thy messiah and in the various means
of playstyle customization the game
affords you enemies in thimesia take two
kinds of damage wounds damage and damage
to their overall health regular attacks
decrease a white wound's health bar
exposing a green overall health bar
underneath the plague causes wounds to
heal automatically so after a short time
the white health bar recharges to the
same length as the green health bar thus
the only way to really damage enemies is
to hurt them with regular attacks then
hit them with a special high-powered
claw attack that specifically targets
the green health bar whittling it down
so you can ultimately drain both bars
and perform an execution move the claw
doesn't really damage the white health
bar but drastically damages the green
one so you need to chain your standard
attacks together with the claw attack to
have a lasting impact the trade-off is
that the claw takes a moment to charge
up potentially leaving you vulnerable so
combat becomes a quick and elaborate
dance requiring you to plan various
moves and string them together with
parries to deal different kinds of
damage while also making sure not to
overdo it and leave yourself open
battling bosses often comes down to
playing defensively with parries and
dodges dealing them wounds damage then
finding an opening to get in some quick
claw strikes to actually hurt them long
term because parrying deals damage to
opponents you're incentivized to attack
aggressively and to master the timing of
blocks turning all aspects of the fight
against your opponent
it's these combat mechanics that make
thy messiah a blast to play especially
once you get the hang of them and fall
into a rhythm the game also brings to
bear several other good ideas that add
to the underlying strong mechanics
borrowed from soulsborne games the claw
attack for instance can be charged up
and at full strength you'll actually
wrench away a spectral plague weapon
from your enemy which can then be used
once yourself as you face opponents
they'll occasionally drop items called
skill shards which give you training in
their particular weapon with skill
shards you can unlock and then level up
plague weapons and then equip them at
thy messiest save points so you can
steal weapons from enemies as you're
fighting them for single-use special
attacks and use the equipped weapons you
brought with you as long as you have
enough of a resource you have to
recharge called energy the plague
weapons give you a wide range of special
moves in addition to your swords and the
claw's ability to steal a weapon from
someone annoying you with it provides a
handy means of changing tactics on the
fly dimesia relies on a similar leveling
system to bloodborne sakuro and the
souls games but with another smart
addition like those games you gather a
resource from enemies you kill that you
can spend at save points to level up
increasing your base stats every time
you do though you also unlock a talent
point which you can invest into one of a
bunch of different skill trees these
give you a host of possible upgrades
like different kinds of dodges a parry
that trades off damage dealt from
deflections for less exact timing a
damage boost to your attacks or the
ability to gain health from executions
that last one really defines how
thymecia feels every enemy is left open
to an execution when you do enough
damage to both health bars so playing
aggressively and racking up kills
restores your health it's a great reward
for pushing your capabilities in every
single fight you can change and reset
skills whenever you want and there are a
wide variety of different ones at your
disposal some require you to build out
specific skill trees by choosing
multiple skills and sometimes picking
one skill tree closes off another one
altogether it all works to allow you to
define a very specific very customized
playstyle between the skill system and
the tight response of combat thimestious
gameplay is highly satisfying adding a
host of new cool ideas to its underlying
inspirations boss fights are where the
best elements of thimestious combat come
together with inventive enemy designs a
group that feels like a soulsborne
greatest hits record you've got your
fast moving duelist your big knight and
armor with a huge sword your giant
monster and your puzzle-heavy fight
filled with regular enemies no boss
fight is similar to the others giving
you a quick smattering of ideas that
challenge you in different ways a few of
them are pretty difficult too with
multiple phases and mechanics it was in
the game's first major boss fight with
an agile disappearing magician called
odurr that the game really hit its
stride and endeared itself to me for the
next 10 hours thymesia also draws on
some of the weaker things about the
soulsborne games and can't always quite
deliver on the inspirations to which
it's trying to pay homage the story is
presented in a similarly sparse fashion
to what the from games are known for and
is similarly disjointed and haphazard
while there are some good ideas within
it i felt like i missed a few major
beats despite having put in the work to
play all the levels and scour all of its
corners what specifically doesn't work
about it is the ending where you're
forced to make a choice without really
knowing what it means or why you're
doing it the plot of thy messiah is
something of a minor concern since the
focus is wholly on the gameplay but
there's enough there that it's clear
overboard or studio cared about the tale
it was trying to tell it just struggles
to land it and as in soulsborne games
levels are huge affairs with multiple
paths that allow you to find shortcuts
to reach different sections over and
over again after you finish the first
memory in one of thimesia's three main
areas you can return to it to delve
further in additional levels fighting
other bosses or uncovering bits of story
those later levels often send you on
different paths through the original one
focusing on specific sections of the map
you've already seen or even sending you
to find pathways into new areas
altogether the trouble is each of the
three big locales is extremely easy to
get lost in and you'll often find
yourself wandering around in circles
trying to find the one ladder or doorway
that you missed the looping level design
makes all the areas feel maze-like and
confusing with backgrounds and landmarks
that are a little too samey to make for
easy navigation and shortcuts that are
rarely important enough to warrant the
effort required to find them generally
thymessia is a quick overall experience
and that can play a little to its
detriment as well there's a decent
variety of enemies carrying a smattering
of different weapons and those weapons
generally determine how those enemies
will fight you'll see tougher variants
on most of those enemies who suck up
more damage hit harder and generally
require you to think about how to kill
them especially revisiting the same
major locations over and over though
you'll run into the same enemy types
quite a bit once you've spent a few
hours in the game a lot of these fights
become trivial as you repeat the same
actions to rip through enemies over and
over tougher mini bosses shake things up
and all the boss fights are a delight
but the smaller scale of thymesia works
against it in making it a little too
easy to get so good at the game that you
tear through most enemies still at 10
hours phimesia is short enough that it
doesn't overstay its welcome you wind up
feeling more like a general badass than
a vastly overpowered killing machine for
the most part and the game's great ideas
culminate in some intense memorable boss
fights while a few elements of the
overall experience don't gel vimessia
understands what matters most about its
inspirations while adding a few spins of
its own to create a small smart and
rewarding souls-like experience
[Music]
you